there was like some spillage and it was
in his chest here okay I was like I
can't touch you anymore I'm done this
over and he betrayed you try to get back
on just alarm oh yeah I was like slide
up the maintenance of hair down there
for a guy I I'm maintaining you should
maintain but don't be cheaper maintained
I appreciate the effort when you just
like took the time to take care of that
like I'll acknowledge that like that's
nice of you
I love to I learn a nice smattering I
like a little bit of chest hair
not a rug but a little bit yeah I like
me I like put my fingers in it like I
feel like yeah yeah I like to do like do
not shave your chest yeah ever I want to
just like run my fingers and just and
then when it goes all the ways you get
out of life happy trail all the way down
not me
nope white guys are Chia Pets it's like
you meet them and they have nothing to
know I'm sudden in a couple much like
j'tia
more often than not I'm just kind of
turned off by a young guy with a
mustache anyone who's got like those
like like evil swirlies I'm going to
match it's usually like a mixologist yes
come ride on my mustache I like our
clean-shaven my got like no beer Bradley
Cooper when he had no beard upside Jimmy
T gooood I was like homeless no think
there's a guy who lives in my building
who literally has like like a long hair
I don't like anything that if it's cold
out or like you're in the snow stuff
will get cotton here Damian I think of
that was like icicles in a mustache and
the beard
like that this guy he went to brunch
with me
he still had Edie Eggs Benedict in his
beard and it was like 8 p.m. obviously I
love like to scrub the beard it's a
problem is if you don't shave for a
couple days it looks cool but then it's
like exactly a view that's the thing and
I love that look but it's the burn from
it they can't make out of our girth
actually I had beard burn when some guy
was going down on me
he was just like like you know when
gossamer you does that happen to you
where you leave me well you've got
leading with a dog ha ha ha I don't
think anymore like if you're an intense
makeout sesh and you need Donnie look in
the mere in your face is red I mean
that's a little I don't mind a little
rug burn it feel good